що олексій вікторович
вода уроком батальйонний комплект зону
що збирали гроші те, що буде буває
дорога легеня буває росія дорога
важливе
дорогий його там все таке повна машина
а грошей скільки це коштує
уалла негорючий і що головна штука
цікава і теоретично на цьому все
можна грати в танчики там до
потужний яловичину і ось це все
зібрано все включено вона проходитиме
і нашим хлопцям це дуже важливо.
вантаж до життя на необхідна яка ціна
цього вантажу до виходу яка ціна яка
ціна життя українського солдата та офіцера
самі подумайте самі тривалих випуску
головне є в інтернеті такі люди
які вміють
але так сказати як це так от з тобою
культурно але чим вони пишуть там щось
кажуть а є ті які ще в мішки
повертати одночасно це виходить
практично ні в кого
тому потрібно намагатися робити це і
в інтернетах
встигати пописати скажемо так і мішки
повертати це що за звичайно не
важка але є такі речі дорогі
зараза дуже важкі тому тут потрібно
якось поєднувати справи грамоти
вдається це дорогого коштує його скажемо
ще одна машинка
а ось сама за мультики дивитися взяв
планшет будь ласка фігасі яким таке в
дев'яності роки можна бачити і
показувати по рублю кинули
пам'ятаєш такі виїзд у нас такі вильоти
пакету
[музика]
тут розумієте кававай директором фірми
дол директор активно торгували потім
війна це виходить визначати
додає тому що було достатньо
груба на якість їде на фронт це що
самий це сам комплект бригадний на
якої ми сімей збирали гроші на
який дав Петру Порошенку
напевно ще буде полуничкою республіки
без розумієте взяли на фронт ні
ніякого сенсу зараз ким су перевіримо
запакуємо і найближчим часом все це
щастя приїду в одну бригаду де вже
фахівці ми змонтуємо включать в
загальну систему відеоспостереження і ось ось
це ось обладнання повторювати ще у нас
рятує життя українських солдатів це
дуже важливо це hyperwarm важливіше за це
висновку сьогодні не але я реально
підтверджуються перевірив за документами
кожну букву це петрів все на
місці корову ми прийняли одну за описом
щоб потім здавати
одну та всі на місці заміряли навіть навіть
діагоналі заміряли
кріплення і кріплення по 10 або ви
потім не знають інакше
коза це нас хотілося б знати господарстві
коментарі господарські
у нас хлопці господарство